this week we're talking about a wide
range of subjects in the cloud I'm Terry
Ryan and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news google kubernetes engine is a great
place to run your containers and running
Windows doesn't change that check out
this post for a step-by-step guide to
running a Windows container on gke and
don't worry we've got plenty of code
samples give you a running start in the
right direction
so copy paste and get your Windows
containers running on google kubernetes
engine moving some or all of your
business to the cloud often comes with a
lot of benefits and that's certainly
true for data warehouses still there are
challenges from upfront investment to
handling security risks to making sure
you only move what you need to move this
post discusses the most frequent
questions that come up from our
customers and help you answer them a lot
functions and other service options work
great when your whole stack Auto scales
but what if your app depends on api's or
databases with rate limits or connection
pools don't worry in this post we'll
teach you all the strategies for making
server let's play nice with the rest of
your stack from tweaking Mac's instance
settings leveraging cloud tasks using
stateful storage or plugging in cloud
pops up we've even got a decision tree
for when you need to use each strategy
fairness and data and machine learning
algorithms is critical to designing safe
and responsible AI systems from the
ground up learn how to apply fairness
analysis at every step of the model
development process then grab the code
samples and get started using the
what-if tool to produce ML models that
are fair for everyone if you want to
read more about these announcements or
just see the full list check out the
link have any thoughts ideas leave us a
comment or tweet us and we'll see you in
the cloud
you